the biggest story really probably while
we were off of these five months was
Trump being put on dry or he's going to
have he's got four trials he's got a uh
I gave hush money to a porn star trial
he's got a I stole documents and put
them by the toilet trial
he has a I asked for 11 000 votes trial
and I tried to overthrow the government
trial
so I just want to say even if you're a
fan that's a lot of Trials
since since he the chances are very good
that he will get convicted of one of
these we thought as a public service
because we're always about the public
service here
put out a little pamphlet called tips
for Donald Trump's sell me he's probably
gonna have his own
film so these are things you might want
to look out for if you are you know if
you're the person who becomes Donald
Trump's Sublime don't believe him when
he says how many cigarettes he's worth
explaining to him that he's not allowed
conjugal visits from his daughter
[Applause]
he loves compliments so tell him that
jumpsuit really brings out your orange
foreign
[Applause]
don't be surprised if one of his cavity
searches turns up Sean Hannity
[Applause]
when he begged some Mexican inmates to
help him get over the wall refrain from
pointing out the obvious irony
let him know that singing YMCA in the
shower might send the wrong signal
look at aggravated when he keeps
referring to his one phone call as
perfect
he's a big eater so don't be surprised
when he takes a shiv and makes it into a
spoon
and finally
when he offer when he offers to blow you
for a Diet Coke make sure you get the
first